[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER: All right.
Let's get started.
Today, we're going to
continue our discussion
of international trade.
I want to finish up discussing
comparative advantage,
and then we'll talk about
the welfare implications
of international
trade, and then how
that drives our thinking
about trade policy, one
of the hottest topics in
economics discussions today.
So let's finish our discussion
of comparative advantage
that we started last time.
Remember, the key lesson
from the PPF-type analysis
we had last time is that if
there's comparative advantage,
it can yield gains to trade
through specialization.
So that's sort of
the key lesson,
is that comparative
advantage yields
gains from trade through the
mechanism of specialization.
So basically, because of
comparative advantage,
you can specialize, and that
means you can essentially
get an outward-bending PPF.
You can essentially
get economies of scope
by specializing and
combining your activities.
Now, you don't literally
get economies of scope,
because each person's
doing their own thing.
But it acts as if the
economy as a whole
is yielding economies of
scope, because basically,
by specializing, you're
allowing the economy as a whole
to benefit from people
doing what they're best at.
So that's the basic
intuition of the economics
of why international
trade can yield gains.
OK?
Now, that raised the
natural question of, well,
where does comparative
advantage come from?
Why do some countries have
comparative advantage?
We [INAUDIBLE] from me
versus LeBron James.
He's got better genes and he's
worked harder than I have.
But basically, when
it comes to countries,
where does comparative
advantage come from?
And basically comes from,
roughly speaking, two sources.
The first source of comparative
advantage is factor endowments.
Some countries, just
through the nature
of geography and
geological history,
are endowed with things that
people want, and therefore
gives a comparative advantage
in trading those things.
So if you think
about Canada, Canada
is endowed with enormous
amounts of forested land,
and they've become a major
exporter of lumber and paper
products over time.
That's their
comparative advantage
because they happen to have
all this forested land around.
So for example, that's why most
clothing today comes from China
and less developed countries.
Because their factor
endowment is cheap labor.
It's not that they have
more natural textile threads
or whatever.
It's just they have
a cheap labor, which
is the primary factor which
goes into producing textiles.
So one source of comparative
advantage is factor endowments.
Now, once again, some country
could have more of everything.
Canada could have
cheap labor and lumber.
But the key point is in
the simple two-by-two world
we're thinking of, it's
all about relative,
comparative advantage.
So it's the one that
have the most of relative
to other countries.
OK?
And the second source of
comparative advantage,
the second reason why some
countries acquire advantage
is technology.
So if you look at
Japan and cars,
Japan has no comparative
advantage of producing cars.
It's not like they have more
of the raw products that make
steel than, say, the US does.
The difference is that
Japan was a leader
in developing the technology
of the modern automobile.
And that technological boost
gave the comparative advantage.
So factor endowments
are kind of natural.
Technology is a created source
of comparative advantage
that essentially, by
developing the technology,
you give yourself really sort
of a first mover advantage,
and are able to then
have leadership,
have the relative comparative
advantage in producing
that good.
That's why, in some sense,
technology policy really
becomes trade policy.
And we'll talk about that
at the end of the lecture
when we talk about
trade policy in the US.
OK.
So that's really all.
I just want to finish up
on comparative advantage.
The main thing's the intuition
we developed last time,
but just want to highlight
also what competitive advantage
means and where it comes from.
What I really want
to focus on today
is the welfare implications
of the international trade,
and why economists are such big
fans of international trade.
So the welfare.
Welfare and trade.
And why do economists, in
simple diagrammatic form,
such strong proponents of
free international trade?
So to consider that, let's go
back to our example of roses,
and look at figure 19-1.
We have here a
simple representation
of the domestic
market for roses.
You've got a supply
curve and a demand curve.
And you yield your consumer
and producer surplus.
So let's say this is for the US.
You've got US
supply of roses, US
demand for roses, consumer
and producer surplus.
Now let's ask, what happens once
we allow international trade?
Once we allow for the
importation or exportation
of roses.
Let's go to the next figure,
which is pretty complicated,
so let's walk through it.
Now we look at the rose
market with imports.
Now, the presence of
imports doesn't actually
change the nature of
demand and supply.
So the domestic or US demand and
supply curves are not shifted.
What imports do is effectively
increase the supply curve
of roses available
to US consumers
by adding roses from
other countries.
So what we do is to make this
work, what we basically--
the trick we use in
these models is we
essentially assume that
in international markets,
there's a perfectly
elastic supply of the good.
So what we say is
international trade creates
a perfectly elastic supply
of rose at the price
P sub W. That is, the price
used to be P sub A for autarky.
That's the price--
where domestic supply
hit domestic demand.
We're going to assume that
what international trade does
is lower the price to P sub W
make supply perfectly elastic.
That is, the US can
get as many roses
as it wants at a price P sub W.
Now, for a small country,
this sort of makes sense.
For a small country,
essentially, they're
like a small producer in a
perfectly competitive market.
For the US, it might
not make so much sense.
The US is big enough
that it's hard to imagine
that we're price takers
with respect to anything.
We're the US, we
don't take any prices.
But in principle,
the basic intuition
we get from this model
works, so we're just
going to treat US as a small
country for these purposes.
And for something
like roses, it's
probably not bad
to think of the US
as a price taker
in the rose market.
So it's a bit of a cheat
to say the US faces
perfectly elastic supply
in the world market,
but it's not a bad
cheat, and it doesn't
hurt the important
intuitions we'll derive.
So we're going to assume the US
faces a perfectly elastic world
supply at price P sub W.
Now, what does this do?
What this does is, suddenly,
at that lower price P sub W,
consumers now want C sub T.
They want a lot more roses,
because the price has fallen,
demand's downward sloping.
But domestic producers want
to produce a lot fewer roses,
since marginal cost
is upward sloping.
If you're going to force
the price down to P sub W,
they don't want to
produce as many roses.
They only want to
produce Q sub T.
How do you resolve this?
You resolve this
through imports.
That the difference between Q
sub T and C sub T is imports.
So the total amount
of roses consumed
does rise from Q sub A to C sub
T. The total amount of roses
consumed does rise.
But the amount produced
domestically falls.
So both things are happening.
Both US consumers are
consuming more roses,
and US producers are
producing fewer roses.
And the gap is
made up by imports.
Kind of a complicated diagram.
Are there questions about this?
Because I'm going to build on
this diagram going forward.
Any questions about
how this works?
OK.
Now let's ask, what are
the welfare implications?
Let's go to figure 19-3.
What are the
welfare implications
to international trade?
Well, the welfare implications
are, for consumers,
their surplus used to be--
their surplus used
to be W. They used
to get Q sub A roses
at a price P sub A.
So their surplus used
to be the area W.
What is the surplus
of domestic consumers?
Let me-- an important
point for welfare.
We're going to look at
domestic welfare only.
We'll come back later to caring
about the rest of the world,
but for now, we only
care about the US.
So when I talk about welfare,
unless I say otherwise,
I think about US welfare only.
US consumers, US producers.
Very important to keep in
mind, because otherwise this
can get confusing.
So for now we're talking
about domestic welfare only.
So for US consumers,
what has happened?
They used to get a surplus of
W. What's their surplus now?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: X, W, and Z.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yes.
Z, by the way, is the
entire light purple area.
It's confusing, because
there's this dotted line
down the middle.
Z's either side of
the dotted line.
The entire triangle is Z.
So consumers now get
W plus X plus Z. Why?
Because they're consuming
C sub T at a price
P sub W. Don't let the other
complications in the graph
confuse you.
Remember, consumer
surplus is just the area
below the demand
curve, above the price,
at the equilibrium quantity.
The new equilibrium
quantity consumed
is C sub T. The new
price is P sub W, so they
get that giant triangle.
Producers used to have a
surplus of X plus Z. X plus Y,
I'm sorry.
Producers used to sell
Q sub A at a price P sub
A. So the area above the
supply curve below the price
was X plus Y.
Now, X has been
transferred to consumers.
So producer surplus has fallen
to Y. So what's happened?
What's the opposite
of the deadweight loss
diagrams we saw before?
When we did things
like impose a tax,
we transferred from
one group to another,
creating deadweight loss.
International trade is
the opposite effect.
We've transferred from
one group to another
and created social
gain for the US.
US consumers have gained.
And on net, US society is
better off by the area Z.
And this, in the
terms of this course,
is why economists like
international trade.
That expands the
opportunity set.
By allowing consumers to
get these cheaper goods,
you raise consumer
surplus more than you
lower producer surplus.
And that's why we like
international trade.
It's a net win for society.
Now, different parties might
feel differently about it,
and we'll come back to that.
But let's just focus right
now on total social surplus.
And for total social
surplus, which
are defined as producer plus
consumers, we are better off.
And that's why we like
international trade.
OK?
Question about that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What is the
new producer surplus?
JONATHAN GRUBER: The new
producer surplus is just
Y. It used to be Y
plus X. So producers
are losing X.
Consumers gain that X,
but consumers also
get Z. So it's
sort of the flip side
of deadweight loss
we talked about before.
You're transferring for
producers and consumers,
but you're also
creating new gains
for consumers along the way.
OK?
OK.
So now, that's imports.
What about exports?
Let's flip and think
about computers.
Let's go to figure 19-4
and talk about computers.
For computers, once again,
we start at point A.
We start with computers under
autarky without trading.
The price is where demand
equals supply, a P sub
A, and the quantity's
Q sub A. And that's
the initial equilibrium
for computers.
Now we open up to trade.
Well, what happens now, is
now, the rest of the world
wants US computers, so the US
can sell at a higher price.
Before, the US could only
sell to domestic consumers.
But now, their demand
for their goods
worldwide-- we don't
show world demand here.
But world demand is
way above US demand.
If you flip back to 19-3, the
reason that that P sub W line
is below the P sub A
is that world supply--
or 19-2 is easier--
world supply is above US supply.
Since supply is higher,
the price falls.
Now, in 19-4, world demand
is higher than US demand,
so the price rises.
So we end up with a P sub
W at the higher level.
What does this mean?
With a higher P sub W, domestic
consumers want fewer computers.
They used to be able to
buy computers at P sub A.
Now they have to pay P
sub W, because they're
competing with consumers
around the world.
So they have to pay more.
So they want fewer computers.
Their demand for computers
falls from QA to CT.
What about domestic producers?
Well, now they're
getting a higher price,
so they want to
make more computers.
So their production
rises from QA to QT.
So you now have consumers
consuming much less
than producers are making.
So the producers send the rest
abroad, and that's exports.
So we have the flip side.
Before, we had-- in figure 19-2,
if you flip back and forth,
in figure 19-2, we had consumers
wanting more than producers
domestically willing to make.
So you had imports.
Now we have domestic
consumers wanting
less than domestic producers
are willing to make,
so you have exports.
What are the welfare
implications?
Go to 19-5.
Now what you get is
consumers are worse off.
They used to have a consumer
surplus of W plus X, where
X is the entire dotted area.
Now, the consumer surplus has
fallen to just W. Remember,
we're doing domestic
consumers only.
There's some people in
Colombia who got computers.
They're happy,
we're ignoring them.
We're just doing US consumers.
They used to get W
plus X. Now they only
get W. Below the demand
curve, above the new price.
But producers,
who used to get Y,
now get Y plus X plus Z.
So you've transferred X
from domestic consumers,
domestic producers,
but you've also given domestic
producers this extra bit Z.
So once again,
surplus has gone up.
So this is the crazy
thing about trade.
Imports raise welfare,
and exports raise welfare.
Either way, whether
the goods are coming in
or the goods are going
out, society as a whole
is better off.
Why?
Because of
comparative advantage.
Because we're better
off as a world
where we can share our goods
across nations, because we
can then rely in the more
efficient producers lowering
the prices for roses in places
like the US, and raise the--
lowering the prices
for goods US consumes,
and raising the price
for goods US produces.
And same with every
other country.
It's literally a win-win.
Every country, by the
need to specialize,
gets to see lower prices
in the goods they weren't
good at making and higher
prices at the goods they
are good at making.
So this transfers across
producers and consumers,
but overall, welfare goes up.
So basically, this
is the bottom line.
These two graphs are why
economists unambiguously--
traditionally-- traditionally,
economists unambiguously
like free trade.
So you get into subtleties,
like caring about producers
versus consumers separately.
Basically, the
logic of last time,
which is a comparative
advantage allows specialization,
means that by trading, we can
allow countries to specialize,
and thereby getting
higher prices
for things they send abroad
and lower prices of the things
they bring in from abroad.
OK?
Questions about that.
And we can see from this
why the notion of a trade
deficit as something
that we should care about
is sort of ridiculous.
Because it's all just
about your endowments.
At the end of the day,
you want to sell stuff
that you have a
comparative advantage in
and import stuff you don't have
a comparative advantage in.
If the rest of the world
has more compared advantage
than you, then you want to
import more than you export.
Doesn't mean you're
worse off, it just
means your consumers
are benefiting
from the fact the
rest of the world
is good at making
stuff like sweaters.
So that segues us naturally
to our important policy
discussion, and one of the main
focuses of public policy today,
which is trade policy.
How do we take this
framework and apply it
to thinking about
government policy
over international trade?
And that's what I'll spend the
rest of today talking about.
So let me just
ask just before we
go there, any questions
about the economics
here, before we start
talking about policy?
OK.
Now, let's start once
again with trade policy
with the standard
economics view.
Which is that you'll
often hear people say,
well, imports are a job killer.
And in some sense,
they're right.
That's what figure
19-3 is showing.
Producers are the
ones with the jobs.
Producer surplus is
falling, so there's
less profitability in
the corporate sector,
so there may be less jobs there.
Now, many people say we should
react to that by imposing
restrictions on imports.
They say, look,
exports are great,
but what about imports
that are killing jobs?
Why don't we restrict those?
And there's two
fundamental forms
of restrictions on imports.
There's quotas,
which is literally
a limit on how much of a
certain good you can import.
Those aren't used
so much anymore.
The more typical form of
import deterrents is tariffs.
Is tariffs.
OK?
And basically, what
these are are taxes that
are levied only on imports.
A tariff is just
a name for a tax
that only applies to imports.
That's what a tariff is.
It's a certain kind of tax
that only applies to imports.
So we could, for
example, levy a tariff
on roses coming
in from Colombia.
If we levy that tariff,
making roses expensive enough,
then folks might go
back to buying it
from the US
producers, and we can
reopen those greenhouses and
the jobs that come with them.
That is true.
What that misses the fact
that US consumers then
suffer from paying
higher prices for roses.
And on net, we're
worse off as a result.
To see that, let's
go to figure 19-6.
So basically, what
figure 19-6 does is
we now start from
the position of being
in international trading.
So before, the other figures,
we started from autarky
and added trade.
Now I want to start
from position with trade
and add a tariff.
So initial equilibrium
is at P sub W,
with consumers consuming
C1, producers producing Q1,
and initial level
of imports denoted
by imports before tariff.
That's where we start.
What the tariff does is
essentially raise the price
back up.
Now, I can't raise the price
above the domestic price,
because if the
tariff's big enough,
you just go back
to buying what you
want for domestic producers.
But it raises it back
towards the domestic price.
So let's say, for example,
the tariff is high enough that
the international--
that the world price--
the price paid in the
US rises from PW to PT.
The gap being the
amount of the tax.
So with untaxed trade, the
US would pay PW for roses.
Now, when we tax trade, that
price goes up to P sub T. OK?
So now, let's ask, what
does that do to the market?
Well, it's pretty
straightforward.
You just say, well, what
is demand and supply
at that new price?
Well, at that new price,
there's lower demand
for roses, so rose demand
falls from C1 to C2.
There's more domestic
production of roses,
so domestic production
rises from Q1 to Q2.
And the imports after the
tariff shrink massively.
The tariff had its
desired effect.
It shrunk imports.
But what does this
do to welfare?
Let's go to figure 19-7.
Now, we can just compare
this area between the two
horizontal lines.
We used to be at the
bottom horizontal line.
Now we're at the higher one.
A, the area A is the
new producer surplus.
Producers used to get the area--
that low triangle
below area A. We
used to call it Y. Now they've
added A. Producers have now
added a new producer surplus A.
But consumers have lost A, B,
C, and D. That entire area is
lost to consumers.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this [INAUDIBLE]
the comparison to when there
was--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah,
that's what I said.
Comparison-- when there
was free trade, no tariff.
So it's a comparison
to the second situation
in figure 19-3.
So 19-3-- and this is
confusing, I'm sorry about that,
but it's too hard to
put it all on one graph.
19-3 is what happens when
we move from no trade
to free trade.
19-7, 6 and 7, I'm
going from free trade
to free trade with a tariff.
By the way, if the tariff was--
brought us exactly back
to the no-trade situation,
it'd just be the flip of
the previous diagrams.
Just makes it a little
more interesting
by making the tariff
somewhat lower than that.
So what's happened
to consumer surplus?
Well, look at this way.
Remember consumer surplus.
It's the area below the
demand curve, above the price.
So it used to be
a huge triangle.
Now what's happened is fallen
by the entire trapezoid, ABCD.
Can folks see that?
Look at the new consumer.
Ignore the fact that it's
four different areas.
Just think of it
as one trapezoid.
The new consumer
surplus is the area
under the main curve above PT.
The old consumer surplus is
the area under the demand
curve above PW.
That's followed by
the trapezoid ABCD.
Now, why do we split
that into four pieces?
Well, first of all, because
A is gained by producers,
so we want to call that out.
That's not a net
loss of welfare.
There's also the area C, the
green area C. C is also a gain.
What is C?
That's the government
revenue from the tariffs.
The government's gained
something from the-- we
get tax revenue.
We can give that back
to consumers if we want,
so that's not lost surplus.
The tax revenue's
exactly the amount
of new imports times the tariff.
So it's complicated.
Now we have this third player
which is the government,
It used to be just
either producer
or consumer, or society.
Now we have this third player,
which is the government.
So the deadweight
loss from the tariff
is B plus D. What we've
lost is B plus D. So
let me go through
the math again.
Consumers lost A plus B plus
C plus D. Producers gained A,
and the government gained C.
So the net loss on the tariff
is B plus D. That's sort of
hard, but do people see that?
And that's why economists
don't like tariffs.
Because the amount
producers gain,
plus the amount the
government raises,
is much less than
what consumers lose.
Yeah, we've produced
some jobs growing roses.
Yeah, we've gotten a
little tax revenue.
But we've really
screwed producers
who now have to pay much
higher prices for their roses.
And if you add that
up, it's worse.
Why is it worse?
Because you're taking less
advantage of specialization
in comparative advantage
by forcing us away
from the most efficient point.
The most efficient
point's where we can
take-- everyone can specialize.
You force that away.
You've put the US,
which shouldn't
be growing roses, back in
business of growing roses.
And Colombia, which
should be growing roses,
gets out of that business.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The tariffs--
where are tariffs applied?
Are they on US--
I guess importers
receive goods, or are
they on [INAUDIBLE]
exporters [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah.
So that's a great question.
I am not expert on
the actual logistics,
but roughly speaking,
when it comes into the US,
into Customs--
so any goods shipped
in the US for sale
into Customs, at that point,
there is a tax levied on it.
Now, I don't know logistically
who gets the bill.
Does the exporting
company get the bill,
or the importing
company get the bill?
When we talk about
taxes, I'll show you
it doesn't matter
who gets the bill.
It's the same either way.
So hold that thought.
But that's basically
what happens.
Good question.
OK.
So with that in mind, so that
is the fundamental reason,
in graphical terms, why
economists don't like tariffs.
But that's not the only reason.
In fact, there's
two other reasons
that aren't even
in this graph why
tariffs and restrictions
on trade policy more
generally are bad.
The other reason is that
they cause trade wars.
So let's say we impose this
tariffs for Colombian roses.
Well, Colombia will
be like, screw you.
If you're going
to tax our roses,
we're taxing your computers.
Well, what would happen if
there was a tariff that Colombia
placed on our computers?
Well, I don't have
that figure, but you
should be able to show
yourself that that is exactly
the opposite effect.
It raises US consumer
surplus, because now computers
are cheaper in the US because
we can't sell them in Colombia.
But it lowers our
welfare, and now we
don't get the
government revenues.
Colombia does.
So we lose almost all the
trapezoid in that case.
If you flip this
around, we would
get a small rise
in consumer surplus
but a huge loss of
producer surplus,
and we wouldn't even get the
government revenues to make it
up.
So that's really bad for us.
And of course, it's
a natural response.
Why wouldn't Columbia do it?
So this first problem is,
this understates, yes, we
might create some jobs
in roses, but we're
going to destroy jobs in
computers, because we're not
going to sell as many
computers as we used to.
So it's not even job-creating.
Once you take in the fact that
other countries retaliate,
in fact, we make consumers worse
off and producers worse off.
Because we make the price
for roses much higher,
and we lose jobs in
the computer sector.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to
diplomatically eliminate this
if you're like a world monopoly?
I feel like a world monopoly--
JONATHAN GRUBER: So
basically, one way
to do it is to come to trade
deals, where you essentially
cartelize countries.
So this is much--
if you could think
of this in very parallel ways
to a non-cooperative oligopoly,
if you can cooperate,
what do you do?
You just get to free trade.
And we'll talk about trade
deals in a few minutes.
That's essentially
what those are doing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why are
current economic advisors
in the government [INAUDIBLE]
tariffs [INAUDIBLE]??
JONATHAN GRUBER: So
let me get to that.
OK.
So basically, what we've done--
and let me answer
the first question.
What we've done is, because
of the archetype made here,
over time, we've created
essentially co-operative
oligopolies around the world.
The one you've
heard of a lot is--
OK.
So I'm sorry, trade
wars is the first thing.
Let me [INAUDIBLE]
the second reason.
The second reason
is that, actually,
as decent human beings,
we might care about people
in other countries too.
And the fact is that there's--
when you-- these both import
restrictions and trade wars
hurt other countries
just like they hurt us.
It's not only we worse off, but
other countries are worse off.
Even without the trade war,
we've made ourselves worse off,
and we've hurt
Colombia, because they
can't sell the roses to the US.
So the reason we don't like--
so the other reason
besides this figure
is that basically, if we
place any weight at all
on the utility of people
outside the US, which we should,
it's bad as well.
Now, I'm not saying you have
to weigh the Colombians'
welfare the same as US welfare,
but as long as it's nonzero,
then that's a second
reason to oppose it.
And that's why there's been
a huge growth in agreements,
the most famous of
which we've heard of
is NAFTA, the North American
Free Trade Agreement,
signed in the early 1990s
under President Clinton, which
essentially set up a cooperative
oligopoly between the US,
Mexico, and Canada.
Essentially, let's just get
rid of these trade barriers
so we can have freer
trade within our regimes.
And basically-- but
this was actually
you know quite popular at the
time, economists liked it.
But it's become very
unpopular over time.
Was opposed by President
Trump, and in fact,
he recently ripped up
NAFTA, although replaced
with something that's
pretty much the same, just
renamed it as USMCA.
So why are people so
opposed to free trade?
It's a great question.
Why are Trump's advisors--
why in fact are the majority--
the majority of
Americans, depending
on how you ask the question,
don't like free trade.
It depends how you
ask the question.
But it's certainly not
universally popular,
like I said it should be.
So what's going on?
Well, there's really a
couple things going on.
The first is that we can't--
we don't.
I wouldn't say "can't."
We don't compensate the losers.
This is the most important part.
What do I mean by that?
Let's go back to figure 19-3.
What's happened when we've
put international trade?
Producers have lost X.
Consumers have gained X and Z.
So it's a simple
economic policy.
If we did international
trade, and then just took
X and gave it back to producers,
no one would be sadder.
Even if we give a
little more than X.
What if we did
international trade
and gave producers
X plus 20% of Z?
Then everybody wins.
That's the [INAUDIBLE].
The problem is we don't do that.
All we do is let consumers have
these super cheap sweaters.
So I get to go buy this
incredibly cheap sweater,
and people in North Carolina's
livelihoods are destroyed.
We don't compensate the losers.
And the winners
don't notice they're
paying $5 or $10
less for a sweater,
but the losers notice
they don't have a job.
So the problem is, yes,
there's more winning.
But first of all, it's
winning among many more people
by a small amount,
whereas losing
is by fewer people
by a large amount,
and that always gets
more political attention.
And we don't have mechanisms
in place, or don't put in--
I started "I can't,"
but it's not "can't."
We could.
We could easily address this.
There'd be a simple policy.
What if we simply said, there'll
be a tax on all consumers
of international-- not
just a tax on consumers,
not of international goods--
that would be like a tariff--
but just a general tax on
consumers of consumer goods
that tend to come in
international trade.
So it's a tax on clothes.
And we'll take all
that money, and we'll
redistribute it
to people who lost
their jobs in the
textile sector,
help retrain them for new
jobs, or help pay their bills
while they find a new job.
Then we could literally
deliver some of X
and even maybe some
of Z to the producers.
But we don't do that.
And that's the main reason,
to answer your question, why
does opposition to free trade?
Is because people see the cost,
they don't see the benefits.
And well-off people like me who
don't need-- who could happily
afford to pay twice
as much for a sweater,
we just get these benefits we
don't even pay attention to,
whereas typically lower-income
workers, because they compete
in lower-income countries, lose
their jobs and they notice it.
So that's one big reason.
The other big
reason is that there
can be socially-damaging routes
to comparative advantage.
There can be
socially-- that sounds
like socially-damaging
routes to California.
Socially-damaging routes
to comparative advantage.
That is, there can be
ways that countries
get to comparative advantage
that are not so happy.
So why does China
have low labor costs?
Partly because they got a
billion and a half people
to work.
But partly because workers
are massively exploited there.
Work conditions are terrible.
And it's a horrible life being
a worker in a Chinese factory.
Moreover, there's terrible
environmental conditions
imposed by Chinese production.
In the US, we have restrictions
that try to minimize,
in some ways, the environmental
damage done by our production.
They don't have those in China.
Or India.
India is home to
three of the top five
polluted cities in the world.
They don't have those.
So by creating their
comparative advantage,
they may be doing damage
that we don't like.
Just like we care about
the fact that consumers--
that we care about other
countries' welfare,
we might also care
about the fact
that this free trade is hurting
other countries' welfare.
So a great example--
I've got a great example.
A very relevant example
was a recent story
about lead poisoning in China.
There was this battery factory--
batteries are big business now--
that made lead acid batter for
motorcycles and electric bikes.
And basically, they operated
in flagrant violation
of environmental law.
They would just dump
the mercury and stuff
they were using in the
rivers and lakes all around.
Flagrant, everybody knew it.
And 233 adults and
99 children were
found to have lead in their
blood up to seven times
the safe amount.
And they're basically
are going to be--
lives will be destroyed by this.
And this is a big issue in
the negotiation of NAFTA,
and a big reason a lot
of people on the left
don't like
international trade, is
because they fear for
the welfare of people
who are being affected.
So when NAFTA was negotiated
in the early '90s,
there were some
protections for workers.
There were some protections.
Basically, the idea was, Mexico,
if you want to sign this,
you got to put in
some protections
to raise the standard
of living of your worker
and improve your environment.
So once again, there are ways
to deal with this by saying,
look, free trade, where you
impose some restrictions,
is still better
than no free trade.
So we might go in and say,
look, once again, it's
all about how you spend Z. You
got a bunch of money to spend.
How are you going to spend it?
Some of the way
you can spend it is
by compensating the producers.
Another way you can
spend it is by saying,
look, we'll be willing
to make it all smaller,
have the world price be a little
bit higher, but make sure you
have decent environmental
conditions and decent wages
for your workers.
As long as we don't impose
too high restrictions,
we could still all gain.
So that's another reason people
don't like international trade.
On the other hand, we taught
the story of the child workers
in Vietnam, and how
free trade in rice
was better for them, because
the parents got richer and had
them work less and
put them in school.
So it's not clear
which way this goes,
but that's certainly
another concern.
And then finally,
there's the issue
which is, I think, paramount
in this administration, which
is trade policy--
trade policy as a tool
of foreign policy.
Trade policy as a tool
Look, consider where we
are with China today.
There's a host of reasons
to be angry with China.
Now, some are irrational.
The Trump's administration
obsession with trade deficits,
as I've explained
repeatedly, is irrational.
It's the Pikachu fallacy.
But some of it's rational.
China-- we operate
under something
called the World
Trade Organization.
Once again, coming to
the other question,
it's another chance to try
to cartelize the country
and set a-- cartelize the world
and set a set of fair trading
rules.
The World Trade Organization.
China repeatedly violates the
rules set up by the World Trade
Organization.
For example, under
those rules, China
should allow much freer
sales of US goods in China,
but they implicitly
restrict them.
Not on paper, but in practice.
They set up lots of
practices which makes
it harder to sell US goods.
They also do a lot of
significant industrial
espionage and stealing
our industrial secrets.
So one way to do
that, for example,
is China has a rule that you
cannot have a solely-owned
subsidiary in China.
If you want a
subsidiary in China,
it has to be jointly owned
with a Chinese company.
Which then will
promptly take the ideas,
and pass them on, and kick
you out of the country.
So China's engaged in
some nasty practices
which are bad for the US--
which are certainly bad.
They may be good for China.
They're certainly bad
for US self-interests.
And that's true.
That is unambiguously true.
The question is, what's
the right response?
And the Trump
administration argues
the right response is tariffs.
The right response is to
punish China through tariffs
for their bad behavior.
And economists--
virtually all economists--
say that's the wrong response.
There is literally less
than 1% of economists
who agree with this policy.
Just a few of them
happen to work
with the Trump administration.
But basically, at
the end of the day,
basically virtually
all economists
agree that it's a bad idea.
And that's for three reasons.
The first reason is
our standard reason
that we think trade is good.
We think we're hurting
ourselves by imposing tariffs
on Chinese goods.
All we're doing is
hurting ourselves.
We're making people
pay more for stuff.
Why would we want to do that?
Moreover, we're
causing a trade war.
China's now imposing
tariffs on our goods,
which hurts our producers.
So our farmers, for
example, are going
to suffer because
it'll be harder
to sell our farm goods in China
because of the new tariffs
they've imposed.
So the standard arguments
we have here still hold.
We like free trade because
it expands opportunities,
and if we try to limit
it, other countries
will respond in a way which
further restrict opportunities.
So that's the standard reason
economists are mad about this.
The second reason is it's
sort of hard to do this.
It's hard to use trade
police [INAUDIBLE] tool
of foreign policy
because it's not
even clear what's made
in China and what's
made in America anymore.
So if we build the
car in America,
but the parts are made in
China, is it an American car
or a Chinese car?
Oftentimes, we'll
have things which
are shipped to China, back to
America, then back to China,
or vice versa.
So it's not even clear what's
a Chinese import or export
and what's US import or export.
These are blurry lines now.
Now, once again, that's all
because of the efficiency
of production.
Basically, what
we've done over time
is we've sort of
disaggregated production
to more and more
efficient components.
It used to be one guy
made the whole car.
Now we recognize there
are certain parts that
are made more
efficiently in China,
certain parts made more
efficiently in Cambodia,
more efficiently in the US,
more efficiently in Germany,
and we put them together.
What that does is it makes
international trade super messy
to understand.
But it makes the
world better off.
It's just further increasing
comparative advantage
and specialization.
But it makes it hard to
decide what's a Chinese good
and what's a US good.
So that's the second problem.
And the third and probably the
single most important criticism
economists make is, this
is a really silly thing
to do by yourself.
The US is big, but
we still represent
a minority of Chinese exports.
We obviously [INAUDIBLE] a large
share, but still a minority.
As long as China can still
sell to other people,
and they're making
plenty of money
off their practices against
us, they might not stop.
Now, they prefer to sell to us.
But if you think
on the one hand,
they're making a ton of
money ripping us off.
On the other hand, they'll
still get to sell 70%, 80%
as much to the rest of the
world once they adjust things.
Then maybe they'll
be like, fine.
We're happy to let you do that.
You're just cutting off your
nose to spite your face.
But if we get the whole
world to coordinate and say,
you violated the norms of
the World Trade Organization,
we're now all going to set up
trade restrictions on China,
then they feel the pain.
So the other reason
economists oppose
this is moving unilaterally on
trade just doesn't make sense.
If you want to try to
deal with these problems,
you need to through
coordinated response.
Now, let me be very clear.
This is a very, very hard issue.
Economists try to
make it very simple
with our surplus diagrams
and stuff like that,
but it's a super hard issue.
Nonetheless, it's an issue where
your bias in thinking about it
should be towards the
basic bias of economics,
which is that if we can
expand opportunities,
that's a good thing.
And the real
challenge is twofold.
How do we expand opportunity
sets in a fair way?
And two, how do we deal
with compensating the losers
as opportunity sets advance?
And this is something
we'll spend a lot of time
on after Thanksgiving, is
how we redistribute society
from one group to another.
OK.
Now let me get some questions.
I know, this is sort of
a top [INAUDIBLE]---- yeah.
AUDIENCE: So on an
international level,
when a country behaves
badly, sometimes
the UN will suggest
that sanctions are
imposed against the country.
And I was wondering if you know
anything about how that tends
to work in terms of welfare?
Like, do the sanctions tend to
make a country behave better,
and then ultimately the
world is better off,
or are those also a bad idea?
JONATHAN GRUBER: That's a
really interesting question.
So let's think about
sanctions in this framework.
So sanctions-- let's say
one sanction would be--
it depends on the
form of the sanctions.
It depends-- et cetera.
So one sanction would
be, literally, you
have to pay a bunch of money.
Well, then, that's just
like a tax on the country.
We just think about that, think
of the country individual.
They're worse off.
The UN gets some money.
In some sense, it depends on
whether the sanction works
or not.
So the easy case is just
simply the trade-off of, do
you encourage a behavior
you want to encourage,
versus what pain do you
impose on the country,
and how do you trade
those two things off?
If they're a really
bad-acting country,
you might not carry
imposing pain on them.
As long as there's some chance
you get the change in behavior
you want, you're happy.
But what if the
sanction's limiting trade?
Well, then you're hurting
other countries too.
Then it becomes a bit trickier.
So then once again, the
trade-off is three-piece.
I hurt the country
I want to hurt.
But I hurt countries
I don't want to hurt.
But I also may get a
change in behavior I want.
So you have to weigh-- you
have to add those three pieces
and put them together.
How do you put them together?
That's exactly what we'll
talk about after Thanksgiving.
You put them together by
thinking about a weighting
function, which we call social
welfare function, which weights
the well-being of all
these different parties
and puts them together.
A very related issue we haven't
talked-- yeah, I'm sorry,
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So do you think that
the current administration is
putting in these policies to try
and gain popularity because so
many people understand trade?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
You know, I think
there's almost no one who
makes any money by trying
to understand what's in the mind
of the current administration.
So I have no idea.
I think China is engaging
in bad practices,
but I also think
it's good politics,
and it's hard to
know what's the mix.
But let's actually relate--
[INAUDIBLE] take the
current administration,
this raises another issue
that's related to all this
which we haven't
talked about, which
is what about immigration?
Another-- I'm going to stop
before I get to abortion.
What about immigration?
Well, immigration,
actually, the framework
is very much the same.
If there are people who can
contribute to our society
by coming here, then
we are better off
by letting them in by the
same logic of specialization
and comparative advantage.
If there are people--
for example, let's say US folks
don't want to pick our crops,
and we don't want
to clean toilets.
But picking crops and
cleaning toilets at a low wage
is a terrific opportunity for
someone from another country.
Then we could be better
off by letting them in.
Or let's say-- as
it's turned out
to be true historically-- the
kind of person who wants take
the risk to immigrate to America
is the kind of person who
often becomes an entrepreneur
and thinks up new ideas.
Much of the entrepreneurial
ideas in America
have come from our nation's
history of immigrants.
Because who picks up and leaves?
It's kind of a
risky thing to do.
To pick up, leave
your home, and leave,
and come to this unknown place.
And those risk-loving
people are often
the kind of people
who think up new ideas
and want to start
new businesses.
So for that reason,
immigration has traditionally
been an enormous benefit
to the US economy.
And I think today, the general
consensus-- this is more
controversial than free trade.
But I think the general
consensus among economists
is that immigration on net
is good for the country,
but there's redistributional
consequences.
It's good for rich
people because they
get low-pay people to pick their
fruits and do their lawn work.
But it's bad for people
who used to pick the fruits
and do the lawn work.
So once again, if
we can figure out
a way to compensate
the losers, immigration
is probably [INAUDIBLE] good.
Now, it's more complicated.
When we import a car, it doesn't
get welfare or commit crimes.
Immigrants might get on
welfare or commit crimes,
so it's more complicated
than just free trade.
So what you have to
do in that case is you
have to look at the evidence.
And the evidence is that
immigrants commit crime
at a much lower rate than
comparable US citizens
and collect welfare at a much
lower rate than comparable US
citizens.
So you can't compare
an immigrant to me.
An immigrant is more likely to
commit crime or collect welfare
than I am, but immigrant's
also less educated than I am.
I'm not the comparable person.
Compare an immigrant
to the person
they're replacing
in the labor market.
A low-skilled US citizen.
Immigrants are less
likely to collect welfare
and less likely to commit
crimes than are those people.
So as a result, those arguments
don't really bode well
for restricting immigration.
On the other hand,
I think there's
very few people who say
we should have a totally
porous and open border.
Because of illegal
movement of goods,
and because we don't want
people objectively criminal
in other countries that
are also risk-loving,
we don't necessarily
want them here.
So I think this is a hard issue.
Unlike international
trade, where
I think economists would
say just more is good,
I think that immigration, there
are some difficult trade-offs,
because people come
with a set of baggage
that goods don't come with.
But I think economists
would generally
say a lot of the
same arguments apply.
We might need a more
comprehensive policy
than we have when it
comes to trading goods.